a pesar de estar completamente vacunado
contra el hobbit 19 colin powell murió
por complicaciones provocadas por el
virus
el mundo perdió a uno de los líderes más
grandes que jamás hayamos presenciado
alma perdió un gran esposo y la familia
perdió a un gran padre
yo perdí a un tremendo amigo y mentor
personal él fue mi mentor durante varios
años
durante cuatro décadas
paul se destacó en diferentes cargos
públicos es veterano de la guerra de
vietnam se desempeñó como asesor de
seguridad nacional bajo la presidencia
de ronald reagan incisivo y pragmático
ascendió al rango de general de cuatro
estrellas y en 1989 se convirtió en el
primer presidente afro-americano del
estado mayor conjunto fue el arquitecto
de la invasión a panamá y la guerra del
golfo para derrocar al ejército iraquí y
expulsarlo de kuwait en 1991 en 1996 el
republicano consideró la posibilidad de
convertirse en el primer presidente afro
camino que no siguió por consejo de su
esposa su legado se había empañado en
2003 cuando compareció ante el consejo
de seguridad de la onu como secretario
de estado cargo ocupado por primera vez
por un afroamericano allí hizo
afirmaciones erróneas para justificar la
guerra de eeuu en irak asegurando que
sadam husein había escondido en secreto
armas de destrucción masiva de sadam
husein you su régimen hecho ningún
esfuerzo para el desarme como lo ha
pedido la comunidad internacional powell
admitió que su intervención tenía
información inexacta lo que manchó su
carrera para siempre en 2008 rompió
relaciones con los republicanos para
respaldar al demócrata barack obama
quien se convirtió en el primer
presidente afro-americano en 2016 voto
por hillary clinton y en 2020 apoyó
públicamente a joe biden nacido en 1937
en el seno de una familia de origen
jamaiquino colin powell fue conocido en
el sector público por su facilidad para
la resolución de problemas